[Music]
Fools Rush In Where Angels Fear To Tread
a leopard doesn't change its spots
never trouble trouble until trouble
troubles you
from Little acorns Mighty Oaks do grow
God helps those who help themselves
where there's a will there's a way
[Music]
a ship in the harbor is safe but that's
not what ships are made for
it's darkest before the dawn
always put your best foot forward
when one door shuts another opens
good things come to those who wait
take it with a grain of salt
bitter pills may have blessed effects
there is no time like the present
foreign
vessel makes a lot of noise
it'll make a mountain out of a mole hill
grief shared is made lighter
an idle mind is the devil's workshop
Time and Tide wait for no man
honesty is the best policy
ounce of protection is worth a pound of
cure
hope for the best prepare for the worst
a thing begun is half done
if it ain't broke don't fix it
barking dogs seldom bite
if wishes were horses Beggars would ride
be slow in choosing but slower and
changing
them join them
you can't teach an old dog new tricks
foreign
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
it's better to be safe than sorry
Beggars can't be choosers
it's easy to be wise after the event